tens of thousands of people continue to
protest in myanmar after a military coup
almost a week ago the internet has now
been restored after being cut for more
than 24 hours but
no one knows for how long the protesters
are demanding the release of the
country's detained elected leader aung
san tsuchi
protesters are back on the streets of
yangon for a second day
thousands marching against the military
coup in myanmar
they used the three-finger salute to
signify their rebellion
and carried banners demanding the
release of elected leader
anseung tsuchi they say they had no
choice but to take to the streets
in support of democracy and against what
they see
as injustice this is really unfair
despite the landslide win in the
election the military staged a coup
unilaterally and with accusations
the military staged an unfair coup they
arrested the leaders elected by the
people
our students under the red fighting
peacock flag
have led revolutions in the past so we
joined today the protest
as well
the red flag is that of ansangsuchi's
national league for democracy
or the nld army chief
seized power on monday alleging fraud in
the election held on the 8th of november
that vote resulted in a landslide
victory for the nld
the country's electoral commission
dismisses the army's accusations
footage of sunday's protests surged on
social media despite the country
battling
internet blackouts the images show
demonstrators out in large numbers
some even facing off against secret
police and military there to observe
them many protesters say they are
determined to show they will not be
intimidated
citizens have already made their demands
by voting
we are on the streets now to show that
we are against a military dictatorship
without fear so far
protests across the country have been
largely peaceful
however gunshots were heard in the south
eastern town of miyawadi
where uniformed police with guns charged
a group of protesters
there were no immediate reports of
casualties
concerns are high that the unprecedented
level of civil disobedience in myanmar
could cause a stronger military response